comedian and actor Maz gibrani has many
admirers in the iranian-american
community and like many members of that
community in what some have nicknamed
terangelis this year's World Cup
presents a dilemma I can tell you how I
feel I've always been a fan of football
soccer my whole life I've played this
since I was a kid I was always a fan of
Team melee but this year it's really
different it's going to be hard to take
any joy in watching it because of the
footage we see coming out of Iran
Iran has seen widespread protests and an
often violent Crackdown on demonstrators
since the death and custody of Masa
amini arrested for violation of laws
regarding how women dress
support for the protests is widespread
in the large Los Angeles
iranian-american community with protests
slogans appearing on billboards and Shop
fronts
the USA Iran match is weighted with
significance especially given the long
history of rancor between the two
countries I like to say that the Islamic
Republic took Americans hostage for 444
days and they took iranian's hostage for
43 years so we're seeing the women of
Iran the Youth of Iran the brains
everyone has had enough do you think
that
there's a feeling of being torn to you
know kind of like honor your Iranian
Roots by rooting for the team or feeling
like that's rooting for something else
instead it's a very Bittersweet time for
Iranian Americans a lot of Iranians are
saying it's not a time to watch football
or to celebrate anything the way I see
it though is I feel that this is a
chance for team medley the Iranian team
to shine a spotlight on what's going on
fork with the people of Iran and and
there's going to be a lot of eyeballs on
that game with as Iran plays the USA Joe
Browne says the World Cup match can be a
significant moment for Iranians
everywhere I hope that there's some form
of
protest and some form of shining the
light on what's going on in Iran
amplifying the voices of the Iranian
people that would bring joy to my heart
and I think it would bring joy to a lot
of Iranian Americans in the diaspora
Joy mixed with grief and concern with
all eyes on a match that is much more
than a game Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los
Angeles